potentially a couple of drugs that are
in humans that made me optimistic that
somebody who might make it to 150 has
already been born in this chapter we're
shown at the possibility to reset the
age of the body up to as much as 50
percent uh uh we can reverse aging in
other issues tissues as well if you can
reset the age of the body multiple times
I think it would be dangerous to set an
upper limit I think it's inevitable he
concluded with these Technologies are
developing now and the speed of
development is getting faster and faster
so I don't think it's far away that
people will live up to 150 years old and
I'll finish up with the store because
they go kind of together from Jeff Bezos
to Jack doors to here's 14 world's
wealthiest entrepreneurs trying to crack
the code of living forever okay Peter
Theo Larry Ellison Larry Page Siri
Sergey brain Mark Zuckerberg Sean Parker
Dorsey Bezos Yuri Milner Dimitri itzikov
David Murdock Robert G Miller Brian
Johnson and wojakov key all of these
guys are trying to so 150 years old Tom
150 years old first of all I know you're
dealing with an anti-aging company right
now the project no don't don't say
anything until you finalize it told me I
was shocked even I don't like the fact
that you're willing to be tested for it
I applaud I wouldn't have done it you
saw but you so you you're the one that
sent me the article that said that I
said I said it's up to but it's you
gotta risk it I'm not going to tell you
to risk it you got to decide whether you
want to take that risk and I know you're
still thinking about it it's a
reversation but we'll see what happens
okay Tom would you want to live to 150
years old
um no I think people are going to want
to tap out of this life long before that
um with with a lot that's going on no no
would I would I like to live you know
what you know I'll live the years that
God gives me and if it turns out I'm
born into a time that I'll live to 150 I
want to do as much as I can with each
moment uh you've already heard me say I
personally don't want to retire you know
I want to teach I want to keep working I
have no desire to get a metal detector
and walk up and down the beach looking
for somebody else's wedding ring you
know not a visual what a visual where we
live in South Florida so you can kind of
see a couple of those guys hey Patrick I
found a watch today all right
Adam 150 would you want to live up to
one I think uh life is precious and I
think you know the longer you live like
I have a goal I want to get to 100
that's just me you know 150 God bless I
think I don't remember who it was I
don't know if it was Neil deGrasse Tyson
or who was exactly and they said the
problem with wanting to live that long
is that you know procrastination is the
killer of success and if you know that
you're going to have a long life and
you've got 150 years to get stuff done
you'll sleep in a little bit longer
you'll hit that snooze button Antonio
Robbins I think gave an amazing speech
about this like stop chasing your dreams
stay in bed just stay in your lane yeah
take a nap so I think you know if you
are going to live that old that you you
kind of not have motivation and
procrastination if I'm gonna look like
that path there's no way in hell I want
to live to be a hundred and that's
that's 100 118. so imagine another 32
years
150 what's up with the guy top left he
looks like he's doing what's up with
that guy he's killing him people are
bringing you play you realize that that
guy was 146 yeah he claimed to be 146.
is that a bullet in his mouth or would
is that a tooth what is that oh look he
got us it's a bullet
yeah here's my thing Pat and at that age
at that age I mean unless you're it's
very keeping up the great oh very tan
but like you're now a burden on other
people because you're not going anywhere
by yourself people are carrying you and
you're an ordeal now
yeah okay
God comes to you yeah you're 75 years
old what's this
Vinnie yes God
you're 75. yep you finally have really
retired because she what Social Security
won 65 it was 70. can you do this in
James Earl Jones just to be yeah very
Vinny yeah this is God yes yeah I got
well done you've lived 75 years and now
they've let you retire in Social
Security thank you I'm giving you
another 75 just to think about the first
75. I don't want that guy I'm good I'm
actually a good guy yeah I don't know I
I don't know all right
would you or not no hell no I'm good I'm
good if I up to 100 Hey listen if I'm a
burden on others hell that's exactly it
hell no I don't like people knowing that
I'm in the bathroom doing my thing now I
have to do it in front people have said
listen I don't want to look like that
that guy looks like a white walker from
freaking Game of Thrones I'm good I'll
say this I think the saddest thing that
anyone can experience is like your
children dying before you or your
grandkids and that's something I get
we're living in like Fantasyland right
here but for everyone you know that
you've ever known and loved to die and
then their kids all day because you live
in other words yeah that could get
aggressive so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]